this is Grammy weekend of course and
aside from the big show on Sunday night
the hottest and most exclusive party is
actually in just a few hours music
industry Titan Clive Davis is host he's
launched countless careers for legends
like Whitney Houston and Alicia Keys
this evening Davis will throw his
pre-grammy party for the forty second
consecutive year and for the first time
in 15 years it's happening here in New
York on stage and in the audience almost
everyone at the annual Clive Davis party
is an A lister for 42 years now the
night before the Grammys Davis has
hosted what's become the record
industry's unofficial annual ball when
it ends
everyone's esto how will you top
yourself do you feel pressure to top
yourself every year I feel the
responsibility you could use the word
person to put on the best show I can the
party started after Davis launched a new
label Ariston and their first record
Barry Manilow's Mandy won two Grammy
nominations in 1976 and so we took over
the Bel Air hotel and Stevie Wonder came
an Elton John came and John Denver came
I knew I was on to a really good special
thing we went along with Clive for CBS
Sunday morning in 2011 that night the
crowd would include Katy Perry Warren
Beatty and Usher why is it such a hot
ticket why is it a hot ticket because
there's no audience like it you must
have a lot of people begging you for
invitations I do have and that's the
most painful part and you have a
limitation so there was a certain amount
of pain when you can say you have a
lifetime pass and it's taken usually
personally it's painful during
rehearsals this week at the Sheraton
Times Square
Clive went over the seating chart with
his son Doug on the other
side of jay-z is going to be Seinfeld
Rob Reiner and the list of performers is
usually kept top secret till the night
itself
but Clive let us catch a glimpse when
logic was rehearsing it's almost like
the Grammys here it's like really weird
you know but it's I think it's really
fantastic
the young rapper is well aware he'll be
performing for an unusual audience it's
kind of freaking me out there's so many
people that like you know and that you
know are gonna be here and they're like
this crazy status and I'm like the most
basic dude in the world so I'm just
gonna show it with my wife and like be
awkward so but it's cool the party's
known for many memorable performances
and one memorable tragedy Whitney
Houston was supposed to be staying here
for her mentor Clive Davis's famous
green Grammy party in 2012 Whitney
Houston died in her hotel room at the
Beverly Hilton just hours before the
event how tough a night was that for you
that was probably the toughest night of
all I do have a very heavy horn Whitney
was there not to perform
it was a favorite night of the year she
would fly there all the time and so on
the same way you don't call off the
Grammys you paid tribute and we paid
tribute do you actually get to enjoy
this night I do enjoy the more in
retrospect than during it but we've had
artists get sick you know the morning of
one year Clive remembers after a
last-minute cancellation he waded into
the cocktail party desperately looking
for a replacement spotting Smokey
Robinson and saying I've got a
ten-minute break in my show smoking no
we have the best musicians can I get you
on stage and of course you said you got
me yes so I'm never relaxed until it's
over do you have a good time when you go
it's the best part it's because you can
walk into the cocktail party and there's
Smokey Robinson there smokey over the
guests the Grammys are tomorrow night
right here on CBS